the official count of confirmed coretta
virus cases in
india has now exceeded 6 million with
almost 100 000
deaths india has the second highest
number of cases worldwide after the
united states
authorities began lifting restrictions
in june despite a big increase in case
numbers
over 60 percent of the active cases are
concentrated in five of india's 28
states
prime minister narendra modi has called
on people to keep wearing face coverings
when they go outside their homes
dw's namisha jaiswal has been covering
the story and joins us now from delhi
namisha
what's behind this dramatic rise in
cases in
india well terry we're looking at a
country with a massive population as
well as a very high population density
and a country that is continuing to lift
restrictions
over the last few months which means
more and more people
are meeting in close quarters this makes
an
ideal breeding grounds foreign a disease
as infectious
as the corona virus now of course the
indian government as well as the people
think they can ill afford to continue
any kind of a lockdown
especially the very strict kind we saw
earlier in the year
because of the economic fallout and
impact of this lockdown and of the
pandemic as well
now while the mortality rate in india
remains low which is encouraging
the country is losing close to a
thousand people on a daily basis
so while this uptick is expected it is
also very concerning
how are people coping with the financial
hardships brought on by the pandemic
well terry people are struggling to cope
with these financial hardships and the
evidence of these hardships
is increasing on a day-to-day basis now
of course right at the beginning of the
lockdown period earlier this year
we saw dramatic visuals and images of
migrants walking home
on foot hundreds of kilometers on cycles
on foot
trying to get home and now things in a
way are resuming to become more normal
as people workers return to the cities
and continue working more and more
things
are opening up but the numbers speak
otherwise india has seen one of its
worst quarterly gdp contractions
over the last few months millions of
jobs have been lost in the formal sector
as well
and while the government has offered aid
to farmers to laborers to female workers
the formal sector is complaining that
not as much air is coming their way
many people within the formal sector who
have lost jobs are now returning to
their home towns
or are choosing to work from home so
this is definitely something that will
involve a long term struggle and also
explains why
india is not reimposing restrictions
yamiche
what do people make of the government's
handling
of this pandemic
well terry while the opposition has been
emphatic and its criticism of the
government of its handling of migrants
of the pandemic
the people themselves have not responded
as
negatively definitely and the prime
minister's immense popularity
may have a key role to play in this
people do understand that
what the government is saying may well
be true that the country must learn to
live with the coronavirus
and the reason the lockdown and the
lifting of restrictions have both worked
so well
is because people trust many people do
trust in this government
however as i mentioned there's
definitely an economic fallout
there is a slow burn amongst those who
are suffering the most
and the true test of what exactly is
people's reaction
may arrive when several local elections
are held later this year
and will the support translate to votes
is the key question here
misha thank you very much uh dw's
namisha jaiswalder on the spiking
infection rate in
delhi and here's some of the latest
coronavirus developments around the
world
there are fresh doubts over the true
number of virus deaths in mexico
the top coronavirus official has said
calculating the final statistics will
take a couple of
years officials have already admitted
that the death toll of more than 76
000 is an undercount new zealand's prime
minister jacinda ardan has
said travel between her country and some
australian states may be possible by
christmas
plans for a travel bubble have been
under discussion for months
and south korea has reported just 50 new
cases of covet 19 its lowest daily
increase in seven weeks
the drop is probably due to stricter
social distancing measures
introduced to stop the spread of the
virus
within the coming hours the global death
toll from kobe 19
is expected to officially exceed 1
million
many parts of the world are seeing a
resurgence of infections such as
brazil's largest city in the amazon
researchers throughout manwas could be
one of the world's
first places to reach herd immunity but
the numbers
say otherwise in may
the coronavirus ripped through the
amazon region's biggest city
leaving a backlog of bodies in its wake
in manaus
cemetery workers could not dig graves
fast enough
but then the first wave of the
coronavirus subsided and in june
death rates dropped unexpectedly
a sense of normality returned to the
city brazilian medical research has
speculated that so many people within
the community had caught the virus
there were few left to become infected
they thought manaus had reached
so-called
herd immunity but this month
covert 19 has been making a comeback
authorities shut beaches and closed bars
and the mayor is angry that the
brazilian government is not sending
a clear message
the government must take this seriously
and tell the truth
to say what is happening and what is not
for two reasons
if it says there is no problem then we
won't get any help
secondly if they say there is no problem
then that encourages people to ignore
our decrees
wing president jair bolsonaro has played
down the danger of the virus
frequently appearing in public without a
mask
and he's encouraging people to go back
to work and return to normal life
back in manaus police break up a party
a 30-day ban on parties came into effect
last week
along with a reduction in shopping hours
regional governments in brazil hope that
with targeted closures
and nightlife restrictions graveyards
like these
will still have plenty of space for a
little longer
you